some 200 Americans have left the
epicentre of China's coronavirus
outbreak on a US government chartered
flight hundreds of others though are
still there the health crisis in Wuhan
has a trump administration thinking of
suspending all US flights to and from
mainland China some major airlines
including British Airways have already
canceled all their China flights the
outbreak is blamed for at least 132
deaths and it spread to more than a
dozen countries and take a look at this
this is at the Wu Han Airport a pilot
put on a full hazmat suit
just to move the airplane the u.s.
flight landed overnight in Anchorage
Alaska where passengers were screened
and the plane was refueled it's now
headed to March Air Reserve Base in
Moreno Valley east of Los Angeles Carter
Evans is there Carter what can
passengers expect when they arrive well
they're going to get more screening the
good news is they passed a screening
test in Anchorage and they are going to
be able to pass another screening test
when they arrive here but they're going
to have to be quarantined for at least
72 hours we spoke with a band who
chronicled his journey as he boarded the
only American flight out of Wuhan
Dule American and British citizen
Ian Thompson's road to the airport was
silent the highways deserted except for
the police checkpoints good news is my
name is on the list so I got through the
first roadblock now he's heading to the
airport
getting through to the medical James
Thompson was one of about 200 people
labeled aboard the u.s. bound flight
from Wuhan I had to get through my
embassy to get here especially a case of
Oh God lucky to be on this flight when
the plane lands at March Air Force Base
in Moreno Valley California passengers
will be led into a hangar where they
will be monitored for symptoms for
anywhere between three days to two weeks
Americans should know that this is a
potentially very serious public health
threat but at this point Americans
should not worry for their own safety
for flights coming from China the CDC
has increased the number of screening
stations from five to twenty including
two land borders they'll all act as
quarantine stations where health workers
will check travelers for illness before
they're admitted into the country
a quick search on social media shows a
lot of people in this area we're
concerned and actually scared mistakenly
thinking that this flight was arriving
full of sick people that is not the case
it's due here in about three hours
Tony you can certainly understand why
people might be concerned though Carter
thank you very much